Mark Zuckerberg was 19 years old when he
started Facebook in his college
dormatory room now known as meta the
company has grown into a global
Empire originally a way for University
students to keep in touch it quickly
expanded to the greater
public within a year it had a million
users by 2012 it had a billion today 3
billion people use the platform every
month a third of the world's
population Facebook was at the Forefront
of a social media reol ution that
changed how we share ideas pictures and
videos
online during the Arab Spring uprisings
activists used it to organize protests
and spread the word about what was
happening in real
time politicians use it to share their
campaign
messages paying meta billions of dollars
for advertising in the hopes of reaching
voters but Mata has faced controversies
over the years data privacy scandals
have led to massive fines from
Regulators I am proud to announce and
many say it doesn't do enough to
suppress hate speech and
misinformation we want to hear more
without Delay about what Facebook and
other companies plan to do to take
greater responsibility for what happens
on their
platforms Zuckerberg has repeatedly been
brought in to face tough questions from
regulators and politicians we didn't
take a broad enough view of our
responsibility and that was a big
mistake
and it was my mistake and I'm sorry but
through it all meta has been able to
outlast or buy out most of its Rivals
Instagram and WhatsApp are among the
many services now Under The Meta
umbrella collaboration which is really
what this is focused on as for the
future Mark Zuckerberg says it lies in
the metaverse Olympic gold medalist a
virtual space he believes will be the
successor to the mobile internet it as
if you're right an evolution of the
business metah hopes will guarantee its
continued success for another 20 years
Vinton Monahan Al jazer El